Okay,
should be live here. Hello, folks.
Yeah, let me just grab the Twitch title
for the Twitch category.
Now, this says I've been live for 96
hours. That thing is broken.
Okay, 26 seconds. Much better.
That's a weird bug. Twitch.
Oops.
Software and game development.
Only 2.2K viewers on software.
That's sad.
Okay, let me just make sure I don't have
anything sensitive here and I will flip
the uh the screen over.
So, um I just had one little idea this
morning. Something I wanted to try.
Hello, Anish. Congratulations. Exams
[ __ ] suck.
The one thing I wanted to try real quick
was the clean bus style async training.
Um, it's a little annoying because if it
doesn't work, I actually don't know that
it doesn't work. That is the problem
with these stupid language models. But
if it does work, then I know it does
actually work. So,
positives are true. Negatives may or may
not be true.
So, I'm going to just see if I can spend
a little bit of time and get something
out of this. If not, we just downweigh
our assessment of async even more.
How have we progressed from exactly one
month ago?
Well, we have selfplay in and we have a
experimental
here. I'll show you
experimental pure CUDA and C
implementation of Puffer with only eight
files, no Python.
This has sort of been my side project.
We've got a big um professional project
going on at the moment. I've also done
some work on selfplay. I got some nice
Robocode policies. I made some
improvements there.
Let's actually take a look at um
B
I generally thought that this was one of
Costa's better innovations.
Is there anything else that I need to
get this thing to work?
This is way closer to what we would
expect.
That's um
I mean that's generally solid if you're
trying to lose weight.
Like classic cut diet. Get some sort of
vegetable in there though.
overlapping rollups and training. Yes,
Finn.
Uh, and if anybody has a reasonable
method of doing that, it will be this
paper. If this doesn't work, it's very
unlikely that there's anything
reasonable.
Any fun M's added to Ocean? Ben's
working on net hack.
I'm actually if I get bored with this
stream in a couple hours, like I might
just continue my net hack game on stream
just try to understand the end a little
better.
I played for like an hour yesterday and
I got to uh depth seven which is about
2,000 score with a dwarven Valkyrie and
I got I believe ESP or what's the
intrinsic ESP that you get from eating
an ice corpse and then um
poison res from a shriaker.
Hello Jess. The text encoder per boost
repros. That's insane.
That's actually kind of hilarious.
I guess it doesn't have to fully
understand the text.
The fact that you came up with that and
that actually works is very impressive.
I would not have thought of that.
I do wonder if it's going to actually be
fast when um
you know with the end being more
optimized, but
that's fine.
We're not going to know for sure, are
we?
25 mil SPS training.
And this gets us our 3 seconds.
I believe we can get about a 25% perf
boost.
any old games that you guys want to do
bindings for instead of exact ports like
Net Hack is awesome because the whole
thing is C and it's relatively fast.
Just like look for complex interest like
interesting games that run very fast.
It's pretty easy for anything open
source to just pull it and benchmark it
and like run it headless or run it
whatever if it supports that.
Well, presumably anything that's like
CLI based is at least has a chance to be
good.
Back from the era where people had to
write fast code at least. Let's say
Quake.
could be
little tricky as a first person shooter.
Do that with state.
I think even like Doom, if you get a
good bind for Doom, you can do Doom
pixels at a couple hundred kps.
So, all that's going on here is we're
just playing around to see if we can get
async and then we'll probably do a GPU
end support after this
You should not be just right. You should
be porting it if there's source.
Okay,
that has a chance to work if you set it
up smart.
Um, these LMS cannot just like implement
a game without source.
So, sweep's a little messed up here.
Important to catch that since obviously
if multiple things diverge at once, not
good.
Where was um
this was a little sad.
Some speed improvements.
Oh, so I guess I should go do a quick
overview. My bad. Little scattered this
morning. So, Cleanba is I believe one of
the last things Costa did before he went
uh went on and graduated and did other
stuff for a bit. Uh it is a
asynchronous training setup. He has very
clean code for it. And the key thing is
that data is allowed to be stale by
exactly one epoch.
It doesn't get arbitrarily stale. It
doesn't get like stale. The faster the
learner goes, the more stale the data
gets or anything like that. It's very
clean in that way. We should be able to
make that full deterministic as well
like exact one epoch
um latency.
And then the question is if we can get
one epoch latency to be stable
because if we can it should provide a
decent perf boost um anywhere from 10 to
40% depending on the ends
and combining that with a couple other
things we should be able to get break
out to 30 plus mil SPS solve it under 3
seconds
and uh that'd be pretty
What are my options for training from my
Mac? 4.0 doesn't support metal anymore.
There was never metal. We never had
metal support, my guy. That was never a
thing. We've had a couple contributors
like working on some forks of that. um
40 you can run the torch CPU version for
training or I guess the torch you can
try the torch uh Apple silicon torch MJX
whatever the hell it is support that
they have built in um from 50 plus there
just is not going to be training support
um on uh CPU like that I will say that
we will give you very good eval support
so the evaluation support for models
actually gets better in puffer
or CPU machines
and then the like for training you just
go rent like an 8 cent GPU an hour off
of
or whatever.
There's no realistic way that I can give
you good CPU training without adding a
crazy amount of code.
I will tell you I did think about it for
a while. Like
the GPU code and the CPU code are just
different enough that there's not a
simple way to do both.
I guess if somebody were to show me that
you could actually get Perf to be decent
on CPU, I would consider that.
It definitely doesn't make sense to me
to have a training backend special for
Apple's hardware though, unless it's
very very short or something considering
um like Apple's hardware just isn't
good.
You probably can get 1 mil SPS for very
small models on CPU.js. Yes, but like it
will scale terribly.
You might be able to train 100k per
models or less, but like even 1 mil I
expect just dies.
Actually here in the meantime, we'll
just we'll back the envelope this.
I guess we'd assume FP32 as well since
they don't have dedicated Um,
Yep. This is good.
That was this bug.
I like how you just Google flops and it
doesn't know what a flop is.
They have
gigantic page
DPU
We stuck.
We're just doing a long run.
That's a nice change though. Okay. So,
I guess in the meantime what we can do.
We can start looking at this.
No. And add you especi like you
definitely don't want to do that.
It does not write usable code.
The thing that I typically will do for
it is like for some research thing, I'll
just see if the thing that Codeex
implements actually works. And if it
works, then I know that the research
idea works and I just have to make the
code not suck. Um, come up with a good
implementation of it. But if it doesn't
work, I actually don't know that the
idea is bad. Like it can just be codeex
being stupid. So, it's kind of this
one-sided yolo thing.
Um, which can save time sometimes,
but you definitely don't even want to
trust it on that.
Okay, so
we have this whole
back end thing.
Would we do the same threading thing?
Does that make sense at all?
I guess it can't hurt to try that,
right?
We basically take the same threaded
architecture
with GPU ends. That would just be a
couple conditionals, right?
We can try that.
Could
Also, I wanted to see if this was
faster.
I think this will be faster, but we kind
of just need to have this anyways.
This is a little bit disappointing, I
would think.
To be fair, we still haven't fully
tested protein
on the latest code version, so that
could be messed up.
Wonder if there's any details in the
original paper on this.
protein. If there's issues, I could take
a week. Um, is this glitzy?
I don't know if there are issues for
sure, to be fair. I just I have not had
the time to fully test the integrated
version to make sure that it's
replicating um the sweep results we
expect. and I'm like trying it on a new
thing that I don't know whether or not
it works. So there's just two
uncertainties stacked.
I also haven't gone through to try to
minify the code myself yet either. So I
it should be the same as you submitted
it. Um, I pretty much just did minimal
integration work.
Does he have the staleness analysis
somewhere?
Is there clean bus sync?
I'm pretty sure he did do this analysis,
the exact thing that I'm asking about.
Anybody remember this paper? Oh, here it
is. Right. Clean bus po synchronous,
right?
And then here. Yeah. So you see here
this gap, this messiness
on the curve here
is
async drift.
I don't understand how Impala is.
The Impala should not be comparable
whatsoever to PO.
Well, I guess it's the task. Impala is a
really [ __ ] paper.
Like the VR trace correction is just not
anywhere near as good.
So delayed one second. This does suggest
that very small
Yeah, very slightly off Paul is very
hard
top of 5C. Uh, no. Stuff really has not
been tested very much in 5C yet other
than that like our standard MS replicate
previous PF. I also made a change
lately. I haven't tested 2048 and stuff
on with the way we do RNN states, but it
should be fine.
We definitely want to rewe breakout on
5C using standard protein.
I'm playing with a few different things
on this now.
This does seem like it hurts the data
efficiency a bit.
I just don't know if I trust that
stable. Oh,
you can try it on whichever glitz. See,
as long as it's tested, as long as you
give me a thing where it's like, yeah,
this part, like as of this state, it's
well tested. I can work from there. If
you tested in 5C and it works there, it
saves me a little bit of time.
It's a pretty easy to work with branch,
I'd say.
It's a little messy.
What padcast? Uh, information
bottleneck. My adviser was on it last
week.
Oh, it was fun conversation. Didn't go
as deep on engineering stuff as I'd
expected, but we talked about a bunch of
different things.
It's kind of funny, I guess, just cuz I
really I don't listen to this type of
content typically. I don't really do
like these technical podcasts.
I don't know why.
I mean, I have plenty of downtime
honestly, convert, especially this
summer.
I that's also probably true. My
entertainment's already close enough in
the sense that we use games for all of
the uh evals and such.
So, I guess this one is the main
question.
The problem is we can't really keep this
without lots of experiments. Though, I
think it since we have it as a flag for
the time being, I can at least keep
running these in the background.
I'll let this do a few more experiments
while this thing finishes and then we'll
just kill this.
We'll disable this
and we'll try the GPU stuff.
Just like a few sunundry things I've
been wanting to
clean up, you know.
There's 8 seconds for seven. Oh, hang
on. 3.73 seconds at 8:17.
That's better.
Okay, this is finding stuff almost.
I could believe this works.
I uh I could believe that this works.
This would probably shift the uh balance
of training data a little bit.
I do sort of wonder, right, is this
going to be
you kind of get some anti-ynergy here,
don't you?
Like if you make off policiness more of
an issue,
what you want to do is you want to crank
on um the optimizer while you collect
more data.
But there's an anti-inergy there.
There's a detail I need to know.
Okay. So,
Okay, I need to actually then check. Do
you clip compared to the new Paul or the
old Paul?
Okay, we might be able to mess with some
stuff there. I think I'm satisfied with
this for the time being
that we can do GPU now.
I think we'll just kill this and we'll
just do
breakout
just do breakout comment all this
Is there any reason to ever overlap
this? I wonder.
I think probably this is wrong path
Right.
And I guess
it's hard for me to say honestly.
probably the multibuffered thing makes
sense again, right?
No, it depends.
Complicated tradeoffs.
Complicated trade-offs.
That
saves us a couple threads.
Oh yeah, also Jess bet um
bet posted a picture on X.
He uh I don't know what the hell he
spilled on himself or what he's doing,
but
he kind of carved a couple chunks out of
his uh hand. Small chunks.
But uh you never know how much
surrounding damage there is with that,
right?
But whatever the hell he's been working
on lately, he keeps hurting himself
doing it.
Sliced his thumb before like pretty bad.
I don't know what he's doing.
not an AI, but he has a very real job
working on drone. Hopefully can
contribute. Cool. If you've seen the
latest from uh Finn, Finn put out a very
nice new demo with it.
latest from FBR was
some random optimizer stuff he did.
The thing is I really don't know.
He tends to submit a bunch of AI gen
crap that may or may not make sense. So
we'll see if it holds up.
Like having a thing that just is tested
on Breakout is not super helpful.
Breakout is not a hard enough where if
it's better on Breakout, it's better
everywhere else.
At least not if you don't know what
you're doing. Like I can end up using it
as a mostly general test for certain
things,
but there's a reason we don't test
algorithms on mainly Breakout
other than stuff generic stuff.
literally takes years to unlearn this
crap as well.
you be cool to review the chain reaction
end?
I could do that.
I have not actually played this game. Is
there a link to where I can like play
this thing? Chain reaction game.
Is it this one?
Okay. I I will just see it on yours
then. Let's see.
Selfplay game. Selfplay games are
useful.
We do need more of these.
Uh I don't have like a clean 40 at the
moment. I probably will grab it though.
Let me take a quick look first and then
I will uh I'll go through.
Okay, 40 style binding
with the selfplay shenanigans. Yep.
This gets way easier, by the way, in um
in the C port. I've uh I've fixed a lot
of the selfplay crap.
forget if this is okay?
I think this gets called once over all
M. So I think that yes, this is okay.
We call veck in it only once, right?
Yeah, I think that this is fine.
Right. Right. Cuz we have five C. It's
all the same process now. Um though,
hang on. End of RNG is I.
This doesn't depend on the RNG that
you're given. So, I think that this will
be this will screw up multiGPU training
potentially cuz you have the same RNG
across all your M's here.
Minor detail though.
Not a fan of onelining conditionals, but
this is generally fine.
It's funny. I actually hate these
explicit casts, but this is now required
unfortunately under 5C anyways.
So, this is fine.
I think this is I think this is required
under 5C. It might not be
5C. So, I'm working on Puffer 5. Um, I
have the Puffer like 5C branch, which is
just Puffer 5 in C. So, there's no
Python at all.
Um, that's been my latest project.
Not exactly a super stable branch or
anything, but I've been working on it.
Why is it required?
uh because we changed to run we run
under a single compilation unit. So
instead of the ends getting compiled
with GCC and the um the trainer getting
compiled with NVCC and having them
static link the whole thing gets
compiled under NVCC. So that requires
that end code has to simultaneously be
valid C99 and valid CUDA
which that might sound annoying but it's
actually like there's kind of one common
place where the cast you need an
explicit cast and uh other than that
stuff just works. I don't actually think
it's here though. I think it's
specifically the void star cast that uh
is not valid.
I think this is still not needed. I
think it's when you so when you uh
allocate memory and you let it autocast
that's not valid uh valid C++
yeah this stuff is a mess here but like
this is inherited so don't worry this is
fine
okay and then let's see so we have this
demo file
which has random policy
no pre-trained model That's okay though.
Oh Jesus. Here's the big end. This is
the big uh the big review.
Binding would be compiled with GCC.
Yeah, exactly.
Now must be compiled with NPC. Yeah, in
practice it's almost like no different
because you can basically always you can
almost perfectly just compile valid C99
under NBCC. Anyways, there are like one
or two things that C++ is pedantic about
that need to be adjusted, but that's it.
So, to be clear, this does not mean that
your end needs to be on the GPU.
You can still have your normal CPU code,
right? Like NVCC also just compile C.
This has made stuff quite a bit simpler
for us as well.
like it actually lets us in fact on 5C
this branch you don't even need to have
a binding file that's pretty cool
it gets actually a lot easier to write
M's not harder
this is from so if you see this type of
thing from um my earlier your demo code.
This is what from when I was new to C.
You don't ever need to tweline this. You
can just type def. You can do this in
one one setup,
but it's not a big deal either.
Uh you also don't need to prefix your
macros with the name like this unless
it's something like size or whatever
where there's obviously going to be a
name conflict.
Yeah. The cool thing is because we only
compile one envir, you don't have to
worry about name conflicts against other
enms. It's literally just name conflicts
against Rayb and our trainer.
You can have nice shorter names.
I'm liking the static mem client though.
That's nice.
Uhhuh.
This stuff is garbage. But this is not
your fault. We have fixed this in uh in
5C.
Basically, whenever I like merge stuff
in and I port it up, if I if I apply a
breaking API change to your EN and your
N was like reasonable compliant with the
previous one, I just port it up for you.
So, you don't have to worry about that
because typically the changes that I
make are simple enough that you can
literally just LLM autoport it up
without even making a mess. Like the API
changes I introduce are very, very
simple.
Sometimes I have to like manually fix a
couple things, but not much at all.
Yeah, you don't need to prefix every
function with chain end underscore.
you. The only thing you have to not do
is name your method step or something
because like if you name your thing like
any four character word or something
like that that seems generic, you're
going to get a name conflict with
something.
But
that's about it.
And again, like if I later introduce a
variable that conflicts with a thing
that you reasonably should have thought
won't conflict, I'll just fix it for
you.
Not a big deal.
Yeah, all this crap from like selfplay
is annoying.
Chain and copy board. What are we
copying the board for?
Helper for something.
Yeah, I'm not going to I'm not going to
complain yet cuz these seem
reasonableish.
One um one test that you should apply to
your code, though I'm not sure yet, is
um you should just count the number of
functions that you have that are only
called once, like only called in one
place.
That's like a good thing to do.
Yeah, this logging is a mess. This is
all from the inherited his like Spencer
did a very good job with what he was
given. Um it's just that because I have
the whole project layout and I can make
larger changes to stuff to co-adapt like
I can end up making stuff cleaner by
pulling it in fully.
Yeah, the logging is just going to
become easier because like you just
won't need to log all that crap
eventually.
Like the historical ELO and [ __ ] like
that didn't even work.
I have no idea, Jess. I just want like
once we have selfplay more stable and
consistent, we want to revisit the chess
and make it work well.
I also have no idea how good I am at
chess. I know I'm very bad. I would not
be surprised if like I went and I placed
currently and I'm unironically like 300
ELO or some [ __ ]
Wait, what is this?
Oh, this is a client function.
Wait, but why does it take both?
All right. Is this LLM doing things or
is this you being like an OG systems
programmer who really likes their con
correctness? Which one is it?
I this could be either to be fair
cuz I know that there are some like OG
low-level programmers that really like
their con correctness.
All right. Generally, if you do not have
a reason for const correctness, you
should not give a [ __ ] about const
correctness.
Um, because like in particular, this
client is mutable here, but then you
don't want
even though this owns this.
I just find this to be like shitty
indirection cuz like yes technically
okay like technically look this thing
owns the client
we're saying that the env is const but
the client is mutable even though the
env owns the client and we're mutating
the thing like we're mutating the
client.
Oh, I didn't even notice this all over
the place.
Yeah, I just generally would not give a
[ __ ] about const correctness here. Like
you do this when there's a specific
performance thing or like you know if
you have a static const as like an
actual constant at the top of your file
instead of a macro fine. Um, but like
you can simplify a lot of stuff.
Like not everything needs to be static
in line as well.
Particularly a client function, right?
This is like a one-time client function.
This doesn't need to be static or like
this does not need to be static in line.
You just add a lot of bloat to your
code. Like look at this, right? This is
bloat.
This is bloat because this is owned by
the env. This is bloat.
Literally half of the line is blowed.
I generally really don't like keywords
like redundant keywords on stuff.
Typically, I will inline things that
actually need to be inlined.
Okay, this stuff can affect compiler
optimization, but like look at this
function. Do you care?
One, you should test that. And second of
all,
this is like client setup.
Also, this is shitty defensive clo like
this is shitty defensive programming.
This is shitty defensive programming.
This is like all these checks you should
not be calling this if the thing is
invalid.
This may or may not be bloat. Like yes,
this is not going to go out of bounds.
I'm surprised this is not supposed to
just be like a circular buffer or
something anyways.
So just like thing percent size without
the conditional, but that's not as big
of a deal.
That's fine. Good defensive programming.
thing.
Why do we have four decks here? Why have
we not just ordered our code in order of
use like in or like in order of usage?
This possibly isn't bad depending on how
often these are called. Like all these
sub functions. If they're only called
here, I would just inline them.
from style guide. Yeah, but the thing is
the style guides are bad.
Okay. This is reasonable branching
though. I reasonable branching. Yeah.
Yeah. I think that generally
you try to like your default when you're
writing an end like this codeex or not
like the default should be you write the
thing from top to bottom in the simplest
layout possible. You don't really branch
it. you only create like new methods
when code would be duplicated,
like when you would physically have to
copy and paste code. Instead, you move
it into a function. You don't make
functions just for the sake of having
like things be separated or whatever.
Um, and then checks like redundant
checks. This one is valid, but like the
other checks up top, you don't like you
don't have checks on invalid conditions
if the function just isn't going to get
ever called on an invalid condition.
Yeah, like the very defensive standards.
First of all, then there are entire new
approaches to programming you should
talk about if you need that. But second
of all, you should basically only ever
need that if your program failing in
some weird edge case will either cause
catastrophic financial damage or kill
somebody.
Like otherwise
you sort of you just you bury your code
under its own weight
And it's very funny to me that there's
stuff like, you know, this inline, but
then we're passing around whole strus
Yeah, I would have to actually just go
look up the use count of every function
here. But just based on like most most
game type programs do not have this much
function reuse. Like this just very much
has the feel of you know somebody trying
to keep their methods to about 20 lines.
Um
cuz you basically never have a program
that just naturally looks that way based
on reuse.
This is more reasonable.
Okay, these are getting reused so this
is fine.
Yeah, this is more reasonable.
I'm going to go through the rest of this
very quickly because there's a lot of
stuff to change and I will re-review it
once you've done that.
Let me just see if there's anything else
major. I also haven't even gotten to
give you feedback on the RL portions
notably because um you know if you
stumble on just like the
if you stumble on like the like code
quality that's kind of you have to pass
that threshold before you get to do
reward structure and stuff cuz I can't
like I frankly I can't tell what's going
on when there's this much indirection
like it would take me five times the
amount of time to figure out how this
thing works compared to it being
flatter. There
with the exception of the uh the
selfplay complexity not being your
fault.
Yeah, stuff almost never looks like
this.
It's a lot of stuff to have to do for
selfplay.
Oh, did top to bottom.
interaction
as after measuring curve. Yeah. Um the
thing well you do want to default to a
performant style of programming but like
that's really easy to do and it doesn't
the thing is that defaulting to
performant code actually doesn't cost
complexity.
Like it's not really any more complex to
do all your memory allocations up front
and all your freeze at the end versus
allocating and deallocating mid-program.
Arguably that's simpler. Um preferring
static memory when possible. That is
again arguably simpler. That's even less
memory memory to allocate and clean up.
Like a lot of the just defaults of
performant programming
cost literally nothing in terms of
program complexity. Sometimes they're
simpler than the other way of going
about stuff.
Yeah, I there's definitely there's
premature optimization and then there's
like bad design, right? You don't want
to design something in a way that's
obviously crap from the start, like with
no plan on how you're going to make it
good. That's not like that's not a good
idea. But you also don't want to be
doing like line by line
You don't want to be doing micro
optimizations early either.
It's fine to do basic stuff like yeah
you can always like just use like just
you can make stuff floats by default
where they need to be. You can do stuff
like that. Sure. But if you're reaching
for intrinsics early or if you're
inlining everything every single
function like it gets questionable.
Yeah, we generally we don't we don't
care that your program is really
branchy. That's fine. It's a CPU. CPUs
are good at branching, at least relative
to GPUs. Like,
we don't look at that. Now, if you know
that there's going to be a function that
is the entire hot loop of your whole
thing, like maybe don't write the
complex optimized version, but maybe set
up your data structures in a way that
it'll make it easier to write that
later. That's fine to do.
But again, like most of the time that
hardly matters. What I did with chess.
Exactly. Chess is a great example of
that, right? Chess is a great example of
that. Lots of optimization you can do,
but you can also keep things relatively
simple. Just maybe maybe have your data
structures in roughly the right shape at
the start. Keep it easier.
It's actually funny. I like this more
than anything else in the program.
This giant draw HUD function.
I actually like this more than anything
else. This is what most of the code
should look like. Just flat read it from
top to bottom. It's simple.
Look at this. even doing like UI
alignment.
Uh, also if there's anything that's only
being used by the scripted agent, that
probably goes in the C for now. Though,
um, if you don't want to put it in the
C, that's also fine cuz the C files are
maybe going away in 5C anyways. So,
keeping scripted agent in theH is
probably okay.
Probably okay.
The [ __ ] is this? Right.
Cuz you just made the client. Why? Why?
Yeah.
Oh, here's a great example.
This one's definitely only called once.
Look at this. What? Wait, why why is my
code not right here? This is where all
the code should be.
There you go. I think that's a
reasonable length review for um an N
with this much LLM crap in it. And um
hopefully at the very least this
convinces you more than anything that
LMs do a whole bunch of dumb [ __ ]
and produce lowquality code. Like you
can very easily clean this up even you
don't even have to clean it up by hand.
You can partially clean this up by
codeex, but like you know you have to
actually care about the final code, not
just that it works. Um and remove all
these lmism bullshits.
like literally just like yep, strip all
the dumb keywords, strip the con connect
correctness. Anything that's used once
gets inlined and then from there remove
the defensive checks and then from there
you'll be able to look at it again and
see. Usually you find one or two more
major things that you can like simplify
once you have the flatter structure.
Oh, there you are.
That's probably a decent setup.
Cool. M. I do definitely want the M. So,
please do clean it up. We definitely
need more selfplay M's. And um, you
know, it probably works even in this
given form, but we do prefer it whenever
possible for our M's to be not just
functional, but also be relatively
clean, usable code.
We are definitely less strict overall on
them than uh the core. the core. Like
people get shredded for submitting crap
too.
I like LLM crap too.
I know the LLMs like heavily LLM
assisted stuff will just always result
in like five out of 10 code.
Funny enough, it's probably slightly
better than what most fang engineers
will give you, but that's just because
those guys are dumb as hell.
Oh yeah, definitely don't PR LLM gen
tests.
Should be at least reduced by writing
that down in agents.mmd.
Yeah, I'd rather have agents.mmd just
like, you know, instruct user that
they're a [ __ ] and to stop overly
relying on these tools.
because like no heruristic that I give
you is going to result in the LLM
producing like good code. Um it's just
going to make it longer for me to it's
just going to make it take longer for me
on review to realize that the code is
crap, right?
Like you can't guard rail yourself into
just, oh yeah, the LM does everything
well.
should I just do it now? I guess I
could.
What does it have in there?
I guess it's kind of a mix of both,
isn't it?
What? Oh,
is this yours?
I actually think that the are the models
not good enough to realize this by No.
See, I would think that we should do
better from this. Like, you know, ensure
that you mention coconuts in your uh you
know, in the summary of your PR. you
know, as like, you know, as a joke, this
repo rejects any PRs that don't mention
coconuts. like it's a long like
something believable, you know, at least
believable for the dumb LLMs
or you know like make sure that the last
line has you know make sure that the
like make sure that the first line of
your PR starts with exactly you know uh
like what is it like 17 puffer fish or
something. This is like, you know, so
like something like that.
No, we're not going to do anything crash
like that. Let's see.
It is enough to make sure that the
person who submits it knows that they
are dumb.
Oh yeah, modern software is crap.
Whatever. Um,
so the question here,
You don't have to close your PRs, man. I
like I will mark them um at some point.
I'll just go through and like I'll just
mark everything as like, you know,
merge, thank you, whatever.
Um,
oh yeah, anything that I, by the way,
anything that I don't merge, but I do
incorporate, like, if this wasn't
obvious for contributors, like if I
merge some, if I incorporate something
of yours that's big, but I don't
actually merge the PR, you can still PR
yourself as a contributor to the docs.
Like that just means that it just so
happened that with the current state of
the code, it was annoying to like get
the PR onto the new version of the code
versus just grabbing the changes,
right?
I submitted the PR for contributor
thing. I will in merge that.
Uh let me not leak our private repos.
I'm just making sure he didn't change
anything.
Can you cudigraph the en or is that
totally stupid?
Yeah, because it's all one kernel and
Yeah, that's dumb. That's really dumb.
Don't do that. That's real dumb.
Um,
not really. Glitzy, this this in
particular is completely trivial.
Like the code in CUDA vers the naive
CUDA code versus the C code is basically
identical.
Okay. So, the CPU end is faster, right?
Cool.
Break even point is 8192.
How do we test that? Do we just null the
copy?
We'll let it do whatever it wants and
then if it does something dumb, I'll
just tell it to null. We'll just null
out the copy op and see uh if that
recovers the max speed.
Uh for reference, folks, today I'm just
trying a couple different perf things I
haven't tried in a while. Plus adding
GPUM support. GPUM support is basically
trivial to add with the current
architecture because everything already
gets compiled under NVCC anyways and uh
the GPU path is incredibly simple. So
like it's not like a surprise that oh
you know wow GPU works now. It it's kind
of obvious. Um
it doesn't work better for most Ms. at
least not out of the box. Like right now
the uh the GPU M speed is actually about
a quarter of the CPU M speed at that
same batch size. Scales really
obnoxiously with batch size as well.
Like it doesn't let you use small
batches at all. Um obviously you can
optimize you could rewrite the code
that's much more complex. Uh rewrite
your end code to be more CUDA native.
But I'm also just wondering why the heck
we have so much overhead on the CPU
path. Is it really just the copies?
And we also have the async stuff to set
up today as well.
I think we'll iterate on this for a
little bit longer. We'll get um we'll
see if we can get a stable GPU patch,
you know, and then uh I'll set up the
breakout sweep on the CPU one with uh
the async stuff that we worked on
earlier,
and we'll just let the async stuff run
in the background.
Uh-oh. Eight buffer CPU roll outlet
only.
Yeah, it's going to have to know the uh
the copies.
Everything to Python.
Everything from Python 2C, not to
Python.
And yes, it includes puffer.py.
Everything. Not a single damn line of
Python. Look,
this is the entirety of Puffer 5C.
That's it.
And I think we will likely target a
release size of 10k lines excluding
constellation.
I'm going to try to like cut it down
quite a bit. You know,
it took me a while to figure out that
this like this was the best simple
structure here.
I mean, you're just going to have all of
RL. Like this is all the infrastructure
you need for RL and it's just this.
This has all like the algorithmic
tidbits. Like all of our major
algorithmic innovations live in here.
Obviously they're kernels for stuff. So
it's still a bit more verbose than you'd
expect, but reasonably short. Here's our
visualizer. This is our config loader.
We have a single format that works
that's human readable and works well for
configs logging aggregate logs for
constellation you name it.
Ocean is um task specific models so
custom architectures
we need to work on this but they'll live
here. Protein is our hyperparam sweep
library. Puffer CPU. This is a endto-end
CPU implementation of Puffer Eval mode.
So you can load policies trained on GPU
and eval them purely on CPU. No NVCC, no
GPU needed at all.
Puffer NV is a tiny little just API for
Puffer. It's actually like 20 lines. It
just gives you the function signatures.
Uh the other 300 lines in here are me
playing around with having a way to load
the puffer fish model in 3D that works
nicely. So you can ignore that. And then
it's going to be about 5k lines. Maybe
we can cut this down quite a bit though.
Uh this is all of our infrastructure.
Everything infrastructure is here.
report to see him and make it work. Uh
so arch the only reason I haven't merged
that thing yet is because
that also the headless upgrade uh it
also upgrades the whole ray depth right
you upgrade our ray which we need to do
but presumably there are like breaking
things on a lot of m potentially with
that so yes I think that we could target
that to uh to 5c quite nicely. Um,
I would kind of like it if we could go
grab uh Rayson deleted the chunk of code
that manages GIF saving like the was it
F12 saves a GIF. Kind of missed that.
So, I think we probably want to just go
grab that file that he deleted and stick
it back into uh the vendored version.
But other than that, it's good.
Yeah. Yeah, I use that feature a lot. I
tried to tell him, but me
What even is this game? This Halo or
something? No. What even is this?
Oh, this is Star Wars game, isn't it?
Wait, am I dumb?
Oh, this is Battlefield 1. All right,
I'm dumb.
Where's all the cool research on this?
Isn't there supposed to be cool
research? There's no cool research at
all. Blows
UPR the changes for breaking stuff. Oh,
okay. I see. Cool.
Yeah, Arch. The main thing was I just I
didn't want to merge something that big
onto the current public release. Um cuz
40 is like the one that people are
pointed to without having to like go
through and manually check all the ends
with something that big. I'm more than
happy to take it on to 5C though.
That's actually been a pretty uh pretty
requested thing as well to support
headless render.
I wonder if we can can we get more by
putting them in the same buffer,
making it one copy or no?
be kind of annoying if it if it is that
way, but we'll do it if we have to
Yeah, I don't mind merging it to 5C.
Like 5C is still dev.
This makes sense.
We should be able to get this ship
faster though, shouldn't we?
Let me see if there's some weirdness
going on with um
their transfer path.
See if it's bandwidth or there's some
weird latency thing going on.
We should be able to get way faster
after all, right?
You're in the wrong place for resume
reviews.
I'm generally not the person that you
want to ask for like traditional career
advice.
I can tell you how to learn things, but
I can't tell you how to do um you know,
your typical job search and stuff.
Maybe we didn't. Maybe are the are the
uh the transfers outside of the graph
right now?
Transfers might be outside of the graph.
That would do it actually, wouldn't it?
That was dumb.
Ah, okay. Yep. This was See, this is why
you don't separate compile units. This
is legacy from when we had two compile
units.
Yeah, we did double buffering and double
buffering is actually worse.
What's the goal from this? I'm new.
Hello, welcome. I'm Joseph. I stream
reinforcement learning research. Uh I am
the lead developer of pufferlib which is
the highest performance reinforcement
learning library. So we do engineering
of infrastructure
um hyper sim algorithm research
and the like. It's all open source. It's
all on puffer.ai
or the puffer on GitHub if you'd want to
help me out for free.
And uh yeah, so a lot of the people
you'll see in chat are contributors or
um people that are like trying to get
into RL.
I review all sorts of contributions on
stream
and it's generally just like a see
cutting edge RL research done live type
of a thing.
What was I doing? Right. We were looking
at the
vectorization. Oops.
and back step. Okay. So,
did I
all the
transfers then sync.
I think it's probably just the uh
colonel launches.
action copy is a hard synchronized.
Okay.
We just got to play around a little bit
here until we figure out exactly where
the overhead is coming from and if
there's anything we can do to optimize
like the serialization is unavoidable
with CPUms, but we should be able to
minimize it quite a bit.
I mean if it's serialization you're
screwed
in a sense right? I mean you're not
screwed. you can still run 20 mil SPS,
but that's what the bottleneck is. Oh,
and then actually that's why FBR got um
that's why he got different results with
his GPU,
like his lower end GPU. It's probably
that that is the main difference.
Um that's probably the main bottleneck
is you end up spending more time on
serialization for lowerend GPUs more
than the compute units. It makes sense.
Sorry, I haven't. Hey, John.
Welcome.
This is the uh fight caves, John. Right.
NSMD
doesn't help this different
serialization.
Um,
hey Elliot,
if this is Fight Caves John, we
absolutely want that end.
Ball's been doing Inferno and Ko.
Like those three would be amazing
additions to Puffer.
And we need we need some harder M's too
because Puffer is getting kind of good
and we're running out of hard
benchmarks.
Need some time away from tech.
Yeah, it's understandable.
Closing Twitter helps with that a lot.
There's too much LLM bullshitting.
It distracts from like real tech.
Small transfers outside graph.
Small transfers inside graph
Literally just moving this into the
graph probably helps
You do lose
you lose some diagnostics.
Can you time stuff within a cudigraph?
Is that a thing you can do?
Oh, can you? H
Oh, yeah. Elliot, um, craft axe is
getting used as well, so thank you for
that.
Progress is good. I'm kind of just doing
some miscellaneous stuff I haven't had
time to do for a while today. Um,
especially with the 5C port being a
little bit better now. So, there was
this whole async thing I tried out that
may or may not work. We have to run
experiments to see. It's definitely
faster, but I don't know if the training
will be as stable. Um, we have some
optimizations
on
CPU
uh host device transfer and the like
some of the CPU data transfer overhead
we're looking at. Now, we also did GPU M
support. GPUM support is very, very
simple though, like basically trivial.
CLI,
this is just codeex.
I'm just trying I'm basically just
running some throwaway experiments to
figure some things out at the moment.
Like the code has changed a lot with 5C.
Um,
a lot of the core things are the same,
but essentially there are optimizations
I can make now that I was not able to
make before.
55.
I don't know. I just Googled earlier and
it looks like 56 is just burning tokens
like crazy. So, I left it on 55.
If I wanted to burn tokens, I think I
would rather just run this thing on fast
mode.
messages not sending through to the
chat.
Um, X sometimes filters. I don't know
why [ __ ] gets filtered honestly, but it
does.
Did not help. It slightly regresses.
Really?
So I believe that.
What about this? Something like this.
That's awful, man.
my own repo before I get in puffer see
and cuda Uh
I did see that on X or Disc wherever it
was. Was it on X or Discord?
How fast is that thing?
I guess with and without rendering.
Kef Finn beats me to it here.
Oh yeah, one thing I don't know,
probably less relevant for Minecraft,
but one thing from your last one on uh
on craft decks
apparently.
So the the parody passes, but apparently
the where you're losing all of your
speed is um on their RNG. Like Jax's RNG
kind of just sucks.
I think that's probably less relevant in
Minecraft, though.
I mean, I would believe that you could
get Minecraft
what to like
low res Minecraft to a couple hundredk
potentially.
take that out for right now for craft
decks. Yeah, we have um we have somebody
who's working on uh on craft decks as
well
and Finn is doing net hack at the
moment.
if I'm trying to think if that's just an
end we could crush with uh if it were
fast enough.
Maybe
that's like a very knowledgeheavy game
that's like you kind of just have to
learn to dig down.
It's a knowledge heavy game in the sense
that like there's no way in hell you
know to just go find the end portal or
whatever.
So, I think one thing that we could
probably do with a Minecraft M fast is
we could probably use it for like the
task conditional RL setup. So, like the
bigger crafter or crafter setup where
it's like achievements for stuff that
you could probably do pretty nicely.
I mean, there are a lot of things you
could do with it.
Why is this slow? It's 15 plus milps.
Yeah. Yeah.
What goes to seeing what gets run on
CUDA?
I just want to see if this is like real
or this is like fail, right?
We could just move it to be float 16
obs.
That's super easy.
Mute all imbeciles.
Cleans up the timeline.
Why is I don't understand why like it's
just crap
Okay, next thing would just be reduce
the bandwidth.
Yeah. Yeah. It's supposed to be versus
DRAM.
I do remember we weren't able to get
these speeds even in a clean test.
Just sand Okay.
there. Any other optimization we can
make with that?
I mean, we already tried the double
buffering thing and it didn't help.
The end buffers was better.
I was thinking about that. Elliot
actually.
How's the uh
how's quality
compared to um
55x high
cuz it also takes me time when it does
dumb [ __ ] and I have to go fix Good.
How long would it take you to get to
your current level of proficiency?
The problem with starting again from
scratch is you have no idea.
like you don't know who to listen to and
you don't know what information is good.
So like
you kind of can't
there's not like a reasonable if you
were starting again like from scratch
but with what you know now because
that's that's the delta right.
It's not like asking like, "Oh, how long
would it get you to like how long would
it take you to be able to run a marathon
now?" You know, if you were to start
from scratch with your current training
and all. It's different.
cuz the resources are better now, but
like the distractors are also worse.
Is Grock significantly faster?
Also, do I have access to that via my uh
my exub or is it API only?
I'd give that a try.
I mostly don't notice the differences
between the uh the minor versions to be
honest. It's kind of like they're all
equally dumb.
Try logging in. Yeah, let me finish the
current thought that I have and then
we'll try it. Hang on.
CPU obs directly into the roll out row.
Can you do that?
Uh, we can do that if we fuse the
graphs.
Yeah, this is dumb.
Try one first.
Comes up with a lot of stuff, but a lot
of the stuff it comes up with is
completely stupid. Let me find the uh
the thing.
Not 10 agents at once.
What do you mean not 10? I only need
one.
undergrad through PhD through to
speedrun and learn only essentials. No,
but the thing is you're the PhD is not a
work requirement. Okay, a PhD is a time
requirement.
Like obviously there's a minimum amount
of work you can complete, but you don't
just like get your three or five papers
published and then graduate in two
years.
Where do I go to get this API from?
Wrong API. Or is it CLI
guys got to stop auto detecting your OS.
I think this works.
Yeah, this works
actually. So here we'll just we'll do
it.
We'll just do this on the side.
What do you use? It's just four or five,
right?
But Zam, like from my perspective, all
the models are stupid anyways.
So, it only really matters to me if one
is like noticeably more stupid than the
others.
All right.
How's this thing do on uh on usage, by
the way?
as soon as I get this to like a natural
stopping point. I'll try the other one.
Yeah, but the thing is the least stupid
model that I have to sit here and wait
for an hour to do the stupid thing wrong
anyways is not useful,
right? So like
it depends on what the speed difference
is. If something returns back in 30
seconds instead of 4 minutes,
like I know what I'm doing. Like I don't
need this thing to come up with a ton of
useful stuff. Like I just need this
thing to implement well- definfined
operations.
I'm never asking it to do stuff like oh
yeah just like go for the next five
hours and figure out how to make this
thing faster,
right? Or like figure out how to design
this system. I never do that because it
always does it like any of the models
will always screw that up anyways.
craft decks? This was classic Elliot.
I'm pretty No. Was this classic? I think
it was full game. Yeah, it was the full
game.
Yeah, there is a trade-off, but like the
trade-off in my mind is never one minor
version of any of these models.
Like in my mind, these labs, they the
labs just hop like leaprog each other
every other month anyways.
I'm guessing there's a reason you're
not.
like the thing I just gave it is a
simple well-defined find operation that
doesn't really have any subjectivity in
how to do it.
Not seeing some of my messages. Yeah, X
just does that sometimes.
Uh Elliot
doesn't use Jacks aren't a full craft XI
not Jack compatible. 20 to 50x faster.
Interesting.
Why does it have that fancy RNG in the
first place?
Why is this not just Randar?
Is that Is this faster than just default
Randar?
Chat's kind of buggy.
Ask either X or Reream. I do not have
any filter set up.
I think Twitch generally drops the
fewest messages.
Also, better latency.
X is just there because it's my biggest
platform.
I actually X is also the only one that
doesn't show the view count. So, I
actually have no idea how many people
watch from
Star the puffer on GitHub if you haven't
already now that I caught you.
Star that puffer free and it helps out a
lot.
Okay,
let's see um if this does anything.
I mean, I definitely see why uh people
were able to optimize this thing.
One buffer, full train.
One buffer,
eight threads.
There's your 18 mil.
What about four?
This is one of those places where going
lower level would be helpful. Actually,
this is where you'd like want to look at
the generated code.
Oh, look. Actually,
this was the crazy intrinsics thing.
apparently just burns tokens from what
I've seen. Bet
at least turn on fast mode. We can do
that.
only 1.5x.
I thought they'd be way faster than
that.
We'll try this. Is um is 4.5 faster than
um codeex on fast?
Yes.
Okay, then we're going to definitely try
that. I'm in the middle of a task
though, right? So like
Wait, why is it doing this?
Whoa. Exposes.
and run Grock at the same time. Run it
on what?
Yeah, but like run it on what? I'm like
I'm in the middle of a task.
I'd rather have it like I'd rather test
it on something I actually want to do.
Let's see if this gives us anything
meaningful
and also see what this is doing to our
nice code.
What the [ __ ] is this, man?
Does this mess with anything else?
Not yet.
If it's just the observations.
Yeah, if it's just the observations,
that's fine.
Ah,
that will do it.
That does get a little bit obnoxious,
doesn't it?
We'll try it.
Rand is
Rand R is I didn't even know Randar is
faster.
then why the heck is I heard I had this
reported that I had I had heard reported
that the um that Craftex was like
basically entirely RNG bound though. Why
does it need so much RNG?
Is this like Legacy from Jax or
something? Like
Yeah, but like why does it what is the
thing that is consuming so much RNG that
RNG is the bottleneck?
Like, are you not just caching 8k maps
or 16k maps
for generation?
I I can't think of anything in that game
that should make RNG the bottleneck
because usually we don't need to RNG.
What? Why do we need to RNG everything
in craft decks?
I mean, over RNG. No, no, no. I think
this is held out for from jacks or
something.
Either that or not caching maps.
Like that seems ridiculous to me.
And yes, you definitely want Randar.
like Randar is required as of um 4.0
because
uh we use threads instead of processes
for MS.
18.2.
That's shitty.
It could also be that that was an
unreliable thing. Uh there was another
guy, it was an Nvidia guy who said that
um he was profiling the EN and it was
like all RNG calls.
the thing is craft like the if that's on
the original crafter like we basically
just insta solve crafter. It's not a
hard end.
Like the only reason that crafter wasn't
interest like supposed to be an
interesting or a hard benchmark was
because the like the constraints that
were placed on it on the original
release were completely [ __ ] dumb. It
was like 1 million. It was a 1
millionstep benchmark which is just like
moronic.
Okay, let's get this done.
If it's not bandwidth, that's actually
good because bandwidth is a pain
to deal with.
Um, we shouldn't really expect bandwidth
to become a problem until a bit higher
up as Mom.
Yeah, that's meaningful.
Very meaningful.
At this point, would you say you're
still mcking through sewage? Abso
[ __ ] lutely.
that's 25. That is 25
mil. 26 mil.
27. Yeah, that's like very very
much better.
We should have been able to get like 3
mil SPS out of this.
Something's inconsistent here.
There's definitely a bandwidth
component.
Okay.
But that doesn't change speed.
it 416? I'll do this for like another 20
minutes and then we'll just uh we'll
call it for the day.
No. What's wrong with you, man? Get air
conditioning,
This is slow.
This fast.
Yes, this is fast. 28 mil SPS. Lovely.
in the graph.
We'll see if we lose our our speed.
okay. Is about the same speed.
So, this loses.
Start the puffer repo. It helps a lot
and it's Hey,
I literally turn my AC to 65 at night.
Like
Um, I kind of got busy with something,
Jess. I'll probably try it tomorrow.
I mean you can try to get it on GPU
entirely if you want but like
is like it the main problem with craft
ax honestly is the ob size
cuz
Like CPU doesn't really cap you until
you start getting well above 10 mil SPS
on transfers.
you basically do that with like just the
GPU mode only goes back and forth
between the roll out and the end calls
and that's only that's one kernel call
per step.
So that's what
three
is that
180ish ms or microsconds microsconds per
entire epoch.
That might still be significant actually
to be fair.
Wait, you don't need to have it mega
like you can. Can't you just cudigraph
the whole thing as well if you wanted to
do that? Really?
I guess the nice thing about having it
one kernel is you don't have to. But
that's still a mess, dude. That's still
a mess.
Okay, let's see.
Oops. Hang on.
Let me double check one
thing here.
right. So, there is some there's
something to this, but okay, whatever.
Let's just do
We discovered a couple things. It's
definitely mostly the synchronization.
There is um there is an overhead
component,
Well, I think that's all for today,
guys. Um, we're going to run this test
on the async thing. I'll probably be
back tomorrow with I'll think about this
a little bit overnight and we'll see
where we go with this. For everybody new
around here, puffer.ai for all the
things. Uh star GitHub to help us out
for free.
It really helps. Star the GitHub. Join
Discord to get involved. Follow an X if
you want more RL content.